[Music]
[Music]
if you have seen the short films from
netflix called love death and robots
then you'd know that there are quite a
few giant monsters and love grafton
entities as well
so here in this video we will list down
the three cosmic horror monsters in it
but before that please subscribe to two
new channels that we have started one is
going to be focusing on prehistoric
animals and it's called mind cue space
and the other is brand new and it needs
urgent support from you guys our family
it will be showcasing content based on
sci-fi tech
real-life technology robotics and ai
and it's called nut bug so support us
fam
now let's get to the monster content
the first one greta the first one is
seen in the episode called beyond the
aquila riff first seen as a friend of
the main character traveling across
space sharing a romantic relationship
with she would later reveal her true
form taken straight from a lovecraftian
sort of story greta the monstrous entity
isn't actually a woman but a creature
that went so much in the dark vaguely
resembles the shape of a human female
when in the dark her thorax resembles a
human head
her actual head resembles a woman's bust
and her limbs have the general shape of
that of human limbs
her real form has a striking resemblance
to an insect around 10 to 15 feet tall
she has six legs in total plus four more
on her belly that allow her to walk on
the hive ceilings she has more than 50
eyeballs on her head and her mouth is a
simple open mouth and leech
she is bathed in slimy liquids that is
pouring constantly it may be the stuff
that makes up the hive's web
she can communicate through telepathy
and can entrance a person into a
hypnotic state for a long time kind of
locked in a space age matrix a sort of
mind control the victim thinking he's
quite okay is actually being drained of
life slowly by slowly over a long period
of time
greta is a creature of nightmares indeed
the second one the queen of the swarm
this monster is seen in season 3's
episode called swarm it starts with a
couple of scientists studying the
workings of a strange and ancient alien
swarm entity they first get quite good
footsteps in learning about the ins and
outs of the alien swarm with the entity
treating them as being benign or at
least a neutral symbiotic species that
lives with its super organism body
they then learn about the many cause of
the swarm and other parasitic and
symbiotic aliens
but soon all this comes to a bloody end
with the swarm detecting their
intentions and creating a new
intelligence cause to push them and the
entirety of humanity as well
just as it has with countless alien
species in the past
the queen of the swarm which is a
brain-like entity in the middle of the
hive is around 30 feet in size it
controls a hive that has existed for
millions of years unbroken and unbound
the queen resembles a giant human brain
with tendrils and tentacles tethered to
the surrounding hive it controls
millions of workers of many different
cars and is also able to duplicate a
more capable clone army of any alien
species that tends to do it harm which
would also include us humans the female
scientist acted as a conduit for it
conversing with the other male
scientists but at a price of the female
with her body being torn and her brain
being taken over by the generals of the
queen
a bloody side indeed and the scene does
vibe with a lovecraftian theme a theme
that shows that humans humanity are just
a tiny insignificant speck in the
vastness of time and space
and lastly cthulhu
and this one needs no reason as to why
it's a cosmic horror monster because it
was a creation of h.b lovecraft himself
and at the center of the entire cthulhu
mythos
it was seen in season 3's in vaulted
halls in tomb
at first the story revolved around a
group of special operation soldiers
recording and trying to eliminate a
group of insurgents with hostages in the
mountains of afghanistan but soon as
they pursue their enemies and the
captured hostage they came into contact
with strange unknown creatures that was
seemingly trying to fend off any human
from entering the treacherous caverns
it became clear that near the end that
these creatures were trying to prevent
the release of the great old one cthulhu
the star spawn the sleeper of arleer
cthulhu is portrayed as always as a
towering behemoth around 200 feet tall
with bat like wings and full flaying
tentacles in front of his mouth
his head is barren with the exception of
numerous yellow glowing eyes he has the
power to take over minds to drive people
insane
mad and bending them to his will he
takes over the mind of the leader of the
spec ops group and beckons him with a
mind call harper another soldier a
female soldier manages to break free
from the trance and sees the true
intentions of the beast
which is to break free from the chains
and destroy kill mutilate every living
being in the world
so after a tough fight she seemingly
defeated the leader of the spec ops
group and had to rip out her eyes in
order to stay alive and escape
but then the fate of cthulhu was left
unknown whether he escaped or is still
trapped is up to you to decide
anyway with that we come to the end of
it so tell us what you think
do hit that like button for support
subscribe as well smash the bell icon
for regular updates on new videos
on this channel till the next one
take care fam